Bo ich hatte die letzten Tage so Migräne
aber ich lasse mich nicht von
irgendwelchen Ausreden aufhalten aber
vielleicht sollte ich noch vorher was
Essen gehen
Spa hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure
malwanne und es ist Zeit für eine
weitere vololge Wanne womentiert
momentare du bist immer mega lustlos bei
der Begrüßung so macht es mir echt kein
Spaß deine Videos zu sehen
lustlos
lustlos okay das kann sein also hier nur
für dich Denise mon hallo Leute hier ist
wieder eure
malwanne
besser ich weiß das nur fürs Video die
wollen das sorry ich habe mir gestern
nach die weinpp geholt ja ich weiß das
ist so
2015 14 13 aber ich komme nicht mehr auf
diesen Clip klar
gehac
er Leute das wird mein neues Lebensmotto
hakun ich glaube ich muss beim Reden
wieder stehen das gefällt mir oder muss
ich dem Reden
wiederstehen okay ich hatte mir den Witz
auf geschrieben aber jetzt ich echt
nicht gut
ist das war jaade so Kelly oh mein Gott
ich sofort damit auf sorry ich nehme dir
ich nehme dir nicht
die ich es ist 1 uh na ach jaaretier ja
okay da steht niemand ich bin so
allein können wir bitte einfach Freunde
sein du bist
cool Melina nachmacherin
was ich habe absolut kein Plan wie iches
Video sorry aber kann das sein dass du
Melina nachmst nein youtu ist ein sehr
großer Teil meines Lebens und so seid
auch ihr ein sehr großer Teil meines
Lebens was soll das warum machst du
Melina nach du siehst noch nicht mal aus
wie sie scheiß und grüße können wir
selbst gehen man wie ich mich über sowas
aufregen könnte
Community wo bist du chill #infobox
danke wie solche Leute einfach nicht
leiden kann das nächste mal bitte den
Bleistift aus der Nase und 3 x 3 macht 4
okay irgendwie siehst du in dem Video
ein kleines bisschen aus wie Emma Watson
ein bisschen wie Emma waton kann t noch
besser werden siehst aus wie Jessica
Alber alle die eine eigene Fernsehshow
haben stehen jetzt bitte wieder auf was
ich wer mir auf meinen Stalking Social
Media Seiten folgst Instagram Twitter
snapchat der hat es schon
mitbekommen
ich Vanessa
freeak bekomme meine eigene TV
show ach ja und dieses soziale
Experiment ist ausnahmsweise kein
prank mein kleines Baby heißt
fantastisch und man kann es jeden
Freitag um
23:15 uh bei nickn sehen wow ja also wer
diesen Freitag nichts zu tun
hat so wie ich der sollte mal wieder die
alte Kiste schmeißen und sich dieses
historische Ereignis anschauen Boom oder
boah eigene TV showow jetzt habt ihr
bestimmt 1000 Fragen wie z.B was ist das
überhaupt
fre bleibst du noch auf
Youtube zunächst habe ich einen Clip für
euch der am Freitag in der Sendung sein
wird exklusiv hier ohne Rabattcode nur
für euch viel Spaß
chuldigung hi Leute ich bin Vanessa ihr
könnt mich aber nennen wie ihr wollt
Wanne
vanessor aber nicht W was ich gar nicht
hasse ist meine Heimatstadt Hamburg ich
wohne zwar schon seit 3 Jahren in Berlin
und liebe die Stadt wirklich sehr aber
mein Herz wird immer im Norden bleiben
so ich Rei mich jetzt aber wieder
zusammen schließlich möchte ich euch ja
noch was mir erzählen eigentlich mache
ich Youtube Videos auf meinem eigenen
Kanal
malwanne und eines Tages dann die Leute
vonck zu mir und meinten hey hast du
nicht Lust etwas mit uns zusammen zu
machen und jetzt ma ich so eine Art
Youtube Videos nur halt im Fernsehen das
Team besteht aus dem kamerakind Chris
und dem kamerakind JS und mir natürlich
ich mag meine kamerakinder aber nicht so
sehr wie meine Katzen ach ja ich habe
Katzen Thomas und Henry ich habe sie
gefragt ob sie in der Show dabei sein
wollen aber sie haben gesagt Katzen
funktionieren nicht im Internet oder im
TV vielleicht haben sie recht was kommt
noch in einen Steckbrief das war süß
oder so mit dem Papierboot und mit dem
Herz und so voll süß wer es
verständlicherweise noch nicht ganz
verstanden hat für den habe ich jetzt
eine ganz kurze Zusammenfassung das ist
do nicht das
zusammenfassungszeichen das ist das nein
keine Ahnung
[Musik]
Zusammenfassung das heißt mein Job ist
es jetzt drei Videos die Woche für zu
drehen diese drei Videos kommen jeden
Dienstag Donnerstag und Sonntag auf den
nicknight Youtube Channel und einmal die
Woche mache ich um diese Clips eine
schöne Schleife und das kommt als
tvsendung be nickn jeden
Freitag das Beste daran ist es kommt
alles von hier nicht von meinen Haaren
sondern von meinem Gehirn also die
Videos mache ich alle selbst nur mit
meinen umpalumpas die mir helfen beim
drehen und schneiden und für die die
jetzt Angst haben dass ich malwanne
vernachlässigen könnte zwei
[Musik]
Sachen ich verspreche hoch und
heiligt dass ich diesen Kanal nicht
vergesse und weiterhin Videos mache
zweitens wer sich gerne die Videos auf
meinem Kanal anschaut der sollte auch
den Nick Youtube Channel Auschecken weil
da kommen ja auch Videos von mir online
das heißt geht quasi da ein bisschen
weiter nur mit einer anderen Verpackung
aber ja immer noch malw dazu kann ich
auf jeden Fall sagen es wird viel DIY
geben ich werde aber auch viel unterwegs
sein also berlinerkunden irgendwelche
coolen Sachen ausprobieren und ich mache
sogar Lifestyle ne so fashion beauty
mäßig aber aber es bleibt alles immer
noch so was ich machen würde also habt
keine Sorgen ich werde mich jetzt nicht
verändern und Beauty Videos machen und
das total ernst Malin sondern ich pack
da halt Schuss Vanessa rein so und dann
mal gucken und wer jetzt wissen will
warum ich nicht auf meinem eigenen Kanal
einfach mehr produziere statt für Nick
zu arbeiten für den habe ich eine
Antwort Videoideen haben ist nicht so W
wenn es dir Spaß macht was aber mega
viel Zeit in Anspruch nimmt drehen und
schneiden klar man kann die Kamera
hinstellen alles einrichten und loslegen
aber manchmal macht es halt einfach mehr
Spaß fürs Auge wenn die Kamera sich
mitbewegt oder sich mal die Position
verändert und das funktioniert halt nur
mit Kameraman und da man für ein Video
auch manchmal 10 Stunden am Schnitt
sitzen kann habe ich einfach nicht die
Zeit so viel zu produzieren ich bin kein
Workerholic wie unge das darf mir nicht
vergessen bitte war jetzt auch mal genug
Information noch mal kurz
zusammengefasst fantastisch ist gleich
Youtube Videos plus Fernsehen plus
Vanessa plus
fre nun geht meine Kinder und verbreitet
die frohe Botschaft dass das Fernsehen
eine weitere unlustige aber doch echt
gut aussehende Moderatorin bekommt
tschüss quatsch ich bin noch da aber
jetzt nicht
mehr y